[Musique]
c'était le point de départ aujourd'hui
la ligne d'arrivée d'une aventure
politique hors norme
zéro jean lassalle a remisé son béret
ses chaussures de marche lui qui était
parti il y a huit mois au chevet des
français revient les jambes lourdes des
6000 kilomètres parcourus mais surtout
l'esprit marquée par la colère du pays
après avoir chanté en béarn et dans
l'hémicycle fait une grève de la faim
pour sauver ça valait le député atypique
a donc marché de paris à lille de l'ill
à strasbourg est encore lyon marseille
bordeaux et bien sûr la bretagne rouge
de colère des paysages différents mais
toujours le même écho n'a plus confiance
il faut faire quelque chose là qui met
bas qui
on nous raconte des mensonges de
baseball hiver de vous allez ouaddou
faire ceci ou faire j'ai peur moi pour
mais mes petits enfants
face aux militants du modem venus
accueillir leurs pèlerins le député tire
la sonnette d'alarmé les esprits
s'embrase la menace du front national se
précise à moins dit il que le pouvoir ne
réagisse
parce qu'une fois de plus
il se rassemblant
aux
secousses et il prendra conscience
qu'il est 23h50
jean lassalle redoutent que ces
municipales se transforme en dernier
avertissement dans les urnes mais
l'homme des pyrénées veut aussi prendre
le temps de la réflexion il se donne
deux mois pour rédiger le bilan de son
tour de france un document qui devrait
finir sa course sur le bureau de
françois hollande
[Musique]